good morning everyone
for being here it's a real pleasure to
be here
so I said my name is chell Bhutto I'm
from the Bureau of Investigative
Journalism Bureau local team these are
the other members of the team and our
twitter handle megan is the leader of
the team before joining the bureau of
investigative journalism she was the
data editor at the Times of London Maeve
and Garrett are two senior reporters who
have won different awards in journalism
and myself I work as sort of the
technical lead and before joining the
bureau I work at trinity mirrors data
unit as reporting on stories for their
local and regional papers on database
stories we are a I think the best way to
quickly describe us is that we are a
data journalism team that collaborates
with local reporters technologists and
anyone who would identify as an engaged
citizen to work on investigative news
stories as long as you are interested in
transparency and Public Interest
journalism we welcome people into our
network and we let people know when we
have a new investigation starting when
we start to work on a new projects and
what opportunity there might be for
collaboration
before I jump further into how we do
that what we do and why we do it and on
a later portion of the talk I will go
through some of her stories what's the
data we use beyond them and how we
collaborated with the network to make
them but I'll make a quick parent issus
about the bureau of investigative
journalism to understand how Bureau
local came to be the bureau was created
in 2010 at the time the newspapers were
on there a lot of financial pressure and
a lot of the teams that were getting
caught were the investigative journalism
teams the reason for that is obviously
that investigative journalism is
extremely costly usually projects can
take months to develop they take more
resource they take more staff under
financial pressure these were the teams
that were getting caught
and the Bureau was created as a way to
kind of fill a void within the industry
the way the bureau works is when we are
done when we have an investigation and
the story is ready we partner and by
partner I mean give the story for free
to the best organization to reach the
right audience for the story so for
example if it's a more of a social
impact story the partner will often be
maybe the Guardian if it's a political
story will partner with The Times of
London if it's maybe a public affairs
investigation BBC Newsnight or channel 4
dispatches would be great partners now
you might start to spot a trend with
those partners that I just mentioned all
of them are still large organisations
that are extremely well-funded and that
all have investigative journalism teams
so when the bureau did an independent
audit in 2015 that was what came back
the idea was so we need to partner with
local journalism those are the places
local regional community papers don't
have those resources how do we partner
with them
since the way we used to work was that
we would just take a story and once it
was ready go to a partner that it would
have required to have journalists in
every area of the UK to do that that
it's not possible for our organization
we're not Restless that way data was a
clear way to do this by having a
national data sets being able to break
it down and then have both regional
stories and a national story to share
the problem obviously being something
that I experienced in some way at
Trinity Mirror that if you try to you
can you have you can understand the data
you can understand that there is an
anomaly that there is a spike in certain
areas but you don't understand the
reason for a spike so we couldn't work
with journalists at the end we had to
bring people to collaborate from the
start so we could mix what the data
tells us with the local knowledge of the
local reporters
for me this goes beyond just telling
stories locally and telling a national
story it's about reconnecting narratives
I would say this is the map of the 2015
general elections in the UK but we had a
party which is people not voting and we
give them a seat if people not voting in
a constituency is bigger than the vote
of the party that won that constituency
and that's the winning party so
basically the winning party of the
election would have been people not
voting this means that the system is
flawed
to me this is partly dude well you could
say it's simply people being
disconnected and feeling disenfranchised
towards the system I think part of it is
that the way data journalism had worked
and by being only and kind of national
media and bigger news organization that
do only or mostly national stories
people were getting fed averages and the
problem with the average is that it's
never really relevant to you so the
person that would you could have a
quarter in the economy where things go
up but the person reading that in
Middlesbrough and Grimsby and Blackpool
in Swansea they will all say no that's
not true they won't feel like they are
being part of a narrative I think that
data makes it a lot easier to recognize
there it is because you understand that
there are several areas experiencing the
same problems and that are maybe going
in the opposite direction to the trend
and then you're not leaving people alone
you're explaining their relation to
what's happening globally or in the rest
of the country and that's what I find
extremely interesting with the potential
for data within local journalism I'll
make a quick tangent because every
organisation as kind of its own
definition of what data journalism is or
definition with the team we have is
pretty simple it's that data journalism
is just journalism but it appeared more
recently so we needed an
and trendy your term for it and that's
why people started saying data
journalism but at the end of the day
[Music]
data when I say data is not numbers
obviously for a lot of people of the
room that comes obvious because we know
that it can be a string and integer
boolean whatever type of data but beyond
that we say so because for us it's not a
number it's digitized information and
it's the same information that would you
have that you would have previously got
from reading hundreds of report but
instead of reading those hundreds of
report it has been digitized and
therefore is available in a larger scale
but it's the same information that the
regular journalists would work with data
is social because obviously it's the
digitized account of the society it
became obvious people started becoming
obviously aware of it with the camera
general if you got story a few weeks ago
like suddenly oh yeah there's a lot of
data about myself on Facebook and on
social media beyond that obviously your
public bodies are the same they produce
reports on their staff the products of
their decision on our public bodies and
for me it's important to take that
information and give it back to the
people who create it in a way and
finally I'll say that data is not lead
it's is a lead it's not the story so we
always start with the data we
investigate it but then we also always
need to partner with the local
journalists to find kind of the reasons
behind it it's often where we become
alert of a situation but unless you're
able to put the context of what's
happening on the ground because there
can always be different reasons for it
we we worked on console finances a lot
recently and you can and the reason that
reserves went down and basically every
council reservoirs level is because they
had to use their reserves to balance the
budget because of austerity but
obviously you have to know that in some
areas that won't be the case the reason
it went down is
because they had flooding problems in
the spring and they had to use it for
flood maintenance and that's a very
basic example but in every case numbers
need to be investigated the the reason I
bring we want to bring tech methods to
journalism is really to that has been my
my slogan and the thing I've been
battling for it's to make the available
accessible if I go back I did my
undergrad in journalism only in
journalism but it became plain obvious
to me I've was downloading more and more
data because I I came from more I had a
science interest as well and I used lots
of statistics and this that data became
my source now if I I decided that I
wanted to be a correspondent in the
Middle East it would have made sense for
me to learn Arabic if I decided that I
wanted to be a correspondent in South
America it would have made sense for me
to learn Spanish but I was working with
data and it made sense for me to try to
learn Python and it's the same way and I
think it helps to try to present it in
such a way where it's not a kind of a
magical way to interact with information
that is hidden in the back end but just
it's like a language to work with a
source the same way I would if that
source spoke Spanish and it's the same
reason why I try to use digitized
information often when I talk with
people rather than data which often
seems like in the mind of some people as
one and zeros in green over a black
screen scrolling up and down but so yeah
decided to learn Python and as I did I I
kind of learned from the community
aspect of it and the fact that I wanted
to do it for my stories it became
obvious that those skills would be
useful not only for me but for a
newsroom and now kuro local is giving me
the opportunity to try and use those
skills not for a newsroom but for local
papers and local journalists and people
who are just curious about Public
Interest stories across the
okay there is an ever-growing amount of
information that is getting digitized
there is an ever-growing amount of data
how dare but that is only available to a
few even when I was a trained to mirror
I could see all these new data digital
interactive team units being created and
how the main news organization but
outside of those news marine
organization those teams don't exist and
there are no one to make sense of those
resources I want to kind and this is
where tech comes in and I want to put
you a little bit in the shoes of some of
those local reporters first of all a lot
of them have now contractual obligations
on the number of stories and even on the
number of clicks they're supposed to
produce in a week so that's not going to
be useful for investigations if they
take time and you don't produce your 25
stories you must do in a week or your
25,000 click you must get in a week
because you worked on a longer
investigation you are in contractual
breach if the paper
happen to be looking to make cuts at the
time well you become an obvious target
since you've breached your contract
there are two main problems time and
resources resources easy to understand
you're interested into trying to find
what are the drugs that doctors
prescribe in your area so you go to the
Department of Health website you
download the file it's a CSV that's good
you're quite good in Excel or even
Google spreadsheet let's say Excel you
try to open it in Excel whoops
the file is more than ten million rows
Excel don't support supports only about
a million in a row so it's gonna break
and your investigation is done for most
people in the room I guess this is not a
problem
we can easily load it with the CSV
module and Python
there is the time problem this is an
example of the time problem it's not the
most well written I just tried to
condense it because when you talk to
journalists
they're like oh it's only seven lines
but yeah you can make it more clear but
the idea being if I try to get just drug
crimes in the UK it's published in
monthly CSVs one CSV per month per
police force so if I try to gather the
early data that's gonna be 45 CSV time
twelve so about 540 CSV that I will have
to open which are all at a few thousand
rows of codes they're obviously
depending the met files the Metropolitan
Police is a lot bigger than on the
Somerset police but you're gonna have to
open those 540 files sort them for drug
crimes and try to not make any manual
error while copying and pasting them to
have a single file of all the drug
offenses if you're looking to compare
your areas with other areas that's gonna
be extremely time consuming and it's not
error-proof while this only takes 22
seconds to run and does the same job
this is why for me it's extremely
important to get more tech resources and
newsroom and to be able to collaborate
I've the tech sector has grown a lot and
especially the open data sector has
grown a lot by collaborating and working
openly with each other and learning from
what others have done before platforms
that obviously come to mind when I say
that or like Stack Overflow where we all
ask each other questions and get answers
and debate on which is the best one
depending on clarity on the time it run
it takes for the function to run on the
memory usage of the function and we also
do the same with like one I've Paul
building on top of what audit work has
been done before like github where we
all search for what other code has been
written and we can just add to it
and then for head back into the repo and
proposed modification that's fantastic
that never happens in journalism never
you you think that people we
in a newsroom what collaborate together
that's not always the case especially in
local papers we talked about the
contractual obligation before if I tell
my ideas to the other journalists and
I'm busy with a work and then he doesn't
know what stories to do and then he does
my story and I have less idea to get my
quota of stories for a week
that doesn't seem productive so it
creates problem in newsroom where even
journalists in the same newsroom
sometimes don't collaborate together
they don't you don't build on top of
each other's work because there is no
legacy news stories are made in the way
that you produce one story and it's done
but there is never a file that gets
published on out the investigation was
done so that other people could do the
same investigation for their own area
these are things that journalism can
definitely learn from and that at Bureau
local we try to bring in so to answer
that for example we do right for every
investigation we do a reporting recipe
that explains how you can go from the
data that we open and we make public oh
you can go and then report for your own
area and where you can find more
information
what are questions to ask about this
data oh look at my nude story
yeah so um sorry about that
the I guess that the the step that
happens when you do all of that is I go
to a lot of open data events and I park
talk to people in the open data
community because we love working with
open data at the bureau a lot more than
doing the traditional way of journalists
which is to do a la is Freedom of
Information request the problem with
Freedom of Information is that almost no
one looks at them you are asking that to
press officer and some department they
will just ask for something to someone
else that will produce a file and send
it to you but if you're trying to do
that for every local authority or
different government departments the
interpretation of your question will be
different within each department because
there is no standard so you will get
very mixed bags answer and it's hard to
run an analysis on that so we like
working with open data but when I go to
open data events a lot of the time
people ask me well how do we get people
to work with journalists how do we get
journalists to work with the data we
produced because there is a lot of of
transparency at the moment where people
produce open data but there is a lack of
accountability where the open data is
taken and then journalists can report on
it and go further and old power
accountable where there are things that
are obviously wrong where we can find
systemic wrong within the open data but
all of that before we can turn that kind
of transparency into accountability it
all starts with making what's available
accessible by taking those large files
breaking them down and making them into
a format that is useful for everyone
even when we think of open formats
they're not really open if the large
majority of people cannot use them I'll
go into more of the stories we did so
this is normally where they should be
the dog that says this is fine with
everything burning beyond him because
one month after we started we started a
year ago we started early April last
year
a month after we started terrorism a and
not even a month three weeks after
terrorism a anons
the snap election for June so we taught
that we would have time to build this
collaborative network probably do a
little tour of the UK go meet local
journalists everywhere set things up
nicely but no there had to be an
election so we had to jump into stories
right away this ended up being a
blessing because we understand from some
mistake and understand how we want to
work with people this was a first
investigation that came out we partnered
with an open tag organization called who
targets me who wrote essentially a
chrome plug-in that you could download
and it would capture every political
advert on your Facebook feed and feed it
back to us so we could see what the
advert was and where it was captured in
which constituency based on the IP
address which obviously can be flawed
but still better than what was available
we then partner with local journalists
and send them the different adverts we
were seeing where there was an increase
in targeted advertising so we were able
to take the data that were target's me
worth taking we were breaking it down to
local level and we were sending to the
Bristol journalists all the adverts
captured in Bristol we were sending to
the journalists in Birmingham the
adverts captured in Birmingham and so on
the interest for that story was that
obviously political parties have a fund
that they can dedicate to their national
advertising during the campaign but
there is laws that forbid the national
budget but for advertising to go into
local elections the local budget for
advertising is much smaller now if
you're doing targeted local advertising
on Facebook which of those budget are
you using I don't think that has been
disclosed by the parties but that's was
what we were trying to raise if you're
using targeted local advertising and you
have the resource to do so which only
which not every party as in equal
measures then there is a problem for
democracy we also during the election
this was or
second major investigation out of four
investigations we did during the month
of the election which was more about
trying to see which voter group could
change the result of the election I'm
happy to say that we're one of the few
news organization in the UK that said
that Theresa May was likely to to lose
her majority or at least avid dented it
felt her editors weren't happy and we
really struggled to find people to
partner with because that was not the
narrative that was being taught at the
time and didn't knew how far we could
push it what happened is we partner with
statisticians to get a model we looked
at the 2015 election which happened
roughly at the same time and the number
of new voters in each of those
constituencies and the total number of
new voters so how new voters were
created everywhere and then we had a
count but only for the whole country of
the number of new voters which by the
way was a bit flawed because it's just
one for every new voters but recorded
digitally also so you could have written
a but that would have clicked on that
button
thousands of times to make it go up but
nobody seemed to have done that so we
were able to come up with a model who
was which was accurate to about 1% to
calculate the number of new voters in
every constituency every constituency
that we would go to on to report on the
piece we obviously call them when we
were close enough to the election and
they had a final count to be able to
make sure that the information we had
was correct there was the new voters if
they were bigger than the margin
counting them as an influential voting
group there was also you Kipp and green
voters because it was a snap election
you keep em greens didn't have the time
to mobilize in every constituency so if
the number of you Kipp was bigger than
the margin last time if the number of
green was bigger than the margin last
time those are all things we looked at
as voting groups that could
swing a seat on their home and the
result was we got about 70 seats from
that about half of which were
conservative half of which were labor
the thing is every labor seat was a seat
they had won every election since the
70s the 50s even the 30s so a Labour
stronghold every conservative seat was a
CD I'd won at the soonest three
elections ago but all in the two or
three last elections so much more likely
that they would go back to voting labor
like they already did in the past that
was the main indication for us that
there was enough c4 to resume to dent
her majority if not to lose it so we
partner with the statistician but also
we organized our first AG day at the
time which was L simultaneously in five
cities we split the team to send the
team and four different ones I was in
Cardiff there was people in London in
Birmingham in Glasgow and in Bournemouth
and we invited people journalists
students anyone who was while were in
the city to come and look at the data
with us the main positive was actually I
bragged on their model a little bit
sorry for bragging or earlier we don't
deserve credit for it we deserve the
credit goes to a journalist from the
local newspaper to Bristol cable who
pointed a flaw in her model because of
house the the possibility for students
to register both at home and where they
go to school and we had to make
correction to the model because of the
local journalist who was aware that this
was an issue in the Bristol West
constituency and pointed it and we
corrected the model and that's what made
the model good it was the collaboration
with the local journalists which really
helped push this investigation further
we did two other small small
investigations during the election that
I'm gonna go over very quickly we did
one on crowdfunding which was
essentially there was a lot of online
crowd funding during the election and
once again you need to be able to if
there's a donation of more than 500
pounds you need to be able to say who
gave the donation and the crowdfunding
websites because of privacy issues are
not allowed to give the information of
the users so you wouldn't have been able
to track those 500 pounds the nation so
technically there would be I like all
the nations in some cases the results
was at the end of the election only a
month after two months after we started
that was already 350 people what signed
up to the network and there was a total
of 75 stories which had been produced
both locally by national partners like
you can see this was the Yorkshire Post
ad lineman Park ads the quad in headline
on dark ads and the I mean hi London
borrows front page on new voters
following that we did we had develop a
good partnership at that point with our
network and what happened is we had the
network starting to feedback to us now
we when we do investigation we invite
people to join into a private slack
channel for each investigation where we
share information where you might have
an intuition about your home local area
which could prove false but by sharing
it with others they can investigate in
their own area and they will find it to
be true where they are and then feed
back to the network and that's where we
try to do a lot of the bringing
collaboration into journalism one person
who had liked working with us during the
election again a journalist from the
Bristol Cable great co-operative
journalism model in Bristol came back to
us said I'm had this Len tfy battle with
the amethyst to check the nationalities
of people stop by immigration or for
officers in in-country operations so not
airports not ports but really inside the
country
and it turns out the vast majority of
people stopped our British citizens now
the guidance from the office requires
their officers to only make a stop or a
check if they have strong suspicion that
the person could have broken immigration
or law now the problem is immigration
citizen cannot really break immigration
law especially when they're inside the
country so this pointed to clear
subsists suspicions of racial profiling
well it's not something we can
necessarily
proof from the data it was something we
could clearly put the fingers on that
there is a clear need for the law to
change and for requiring immigration
officers to at least have some sort of
having to fill in the report what the
ethnicity of the person was or after the
person decide if they want to say what
their ethnicity was to be able to prove
if there's racial profiling or not the
interesting thing in this case also was
that by partnering with local
journalists in lots of areas those
journalists were all able to have access
to their local MPs so we had about 15
MPs speaking on that story tree of them
raised it in the house so there was a
clear impact that we wouldn't have been
able to have if we had worked alone we
would have talked maybe to two or three
MPs getting comments and then published
them in our story and that would I mean
it because we partner with the local
journalists we had a lot more comments
from a lot more MP and it brought
attention to the issue we were raising
which was raised in Parliament and both
brought further I just put this because
this was kind of a I I I'm a big
apologist and that there's a two trends
to school of journalism and when it
comes to data journalism at the moment
that's not something that people in
academia say that's just my feeling I
would describe it as the American school
and the the German school and the
American school is very much into
Interactive's
and how you visualize data to be able to
communicate the story better myself I'm
closer to the German school which is I
think closer to the fightin community in
a way by being more into what's
happening on the backend how do I take
several data files and merge them
together out can I extract meaningful
information from large data set and then
if the visualization is not the best
option because it's just dance and text
is enough but you have found the
information true taking lots of PDFs
turn them into text file then treated
the text files with Python then that's
maybe more you reach other conclusion
but we also do data visualizations when
the case is interesting in this case it
was
looking at the rise of forms requesting
permits for intensive farming in the UK
it's quite fun it becomes looks kind of
a disease at the end where you start in
2005 now and there's 47 and by the end
we're over 1,000 in 2012 so it really
exploded in the last decades the number
of farms having permit for intensive
farming oh this should have been before
that's about the impact we had for the
immigration story which made the
Guardian and the front page of the
Bristol cable and was also shared in
various local paper and clearly proved
to us the work of what we were doing and
having the network collaborate and bring
stories forward to share with other
local journalists that's what I said
before you you have problems with
journalists collaborating together
within their own newsroom now we had for
that story a journalist wanting to share
the result of his foi with everyone he
said I made DF why I was able to get the
data for 11 major urban centres in the
UK I'm gonna report on Bristol and I
wanted to be able to compare with other
cities but like it does it would be a
waste if I made that FY and it would
only be reported in Bristol that's why
you wanted to bring it to the network
and which by doing so we had much more
impact
otherwise this is a story we done dead
on domestic violence last autumn a
series of report which was done by a mix
of FY open data and surveys - refuge
managers which were all mixed together
to look at the pressure that domestic
violence refuges are under to give you
an idea there was a women in Birmingham
ooh
the refuge at two closed and she had to
be moved elsewhere and the closest place
they could find that was available at
the same time was in the islands to the
north of Scotland which is quite far
from Birmingham to say the least and one
of the interesting thing for this
investigation was also to kind of by
having all those mixed set of data to be
able to have
Micke stories by bringing them together
we could have the story of talking about
the cuts we could have the story of
taking about the delays from when money
was agreed by the government to for
funding refugees but the refuge only
received them the money about six to
twelve months later now if you were
expecting that while it was supposed to
arrive two or three months later so if
you said oh it's good in two-three
months I'm gonna have my money and then
it arrives six months after that you
found yourself in a lot of pressures and
you might have to close before the money
arrives we were also yeah so all sorts
of stories that came about at that and
then we kept working on the story
talking about the laws that were put in
place to help fight domestic abuse but
that are really being patchy at the
moment such as controlling and coercive
behavior or Clair's law the the another
thing that's interesting one result of
that investigation is we followed there
was a refuge where the roof collapsed
and Westminster and Maeve was the lead
reporter and the story followed the
women that were in that refuges as they
were playing place to another refuge for
maybe six months it took and one of them
was a stand-up comedian so there's
always also going to be kind of a tour
where we're gonna go with that comedian
in every local area and talk and she was
gonna do her show every local area that
was not every but like eight local areas
where local reporters worked with us on
the investigation and she's gonna do a
show in the first part and then the
second part Maeve is gonna go on stage
with the local journalist and ER and
they're gonna be able to talk more about
what the issue was from status point of
view which is all about trying to reach
as many people as you can and making
sure that people engage with an
investigation which I find quite
interesting
the following story
the following big project we worked on
was council finances the problem being
council are required to produce budgets
of how they plan to spend money in a
year they're required to to produce and
to send to the government their budget
they're required to produce and send to
the central government their out turns
on how they did spend the money but
they're on they have they produce drafts
which are never centralized but the
drafts which we usually come between in
January and February add of the of the
budgets being proposed in March contains
lots of information about the cuts they
plan to make but are never centralized
so the public never get the chance to
have their say on what drafts really
suggest or have an idea of what drafts
budgets are on a national level and I've
a say before they become law effectively
when the budget is parts passed in March
so we were to centralize all the budgets
and look at which country can which
council was over spending which planning
historically and planning to cuts as a
result in key area like adult services
and Children Services obviously the
drafts council produce are all extremely
different you have to go to all the
different websites to be able to get
them of the 350 council and go to the
report and try to centralize it all
together so without dec work it's an
extremely as artists task we also
organize the hack day from it which was
good in that one we compile historic
data which is produced yearly on service
level spending and put it all together
for the last five years which become a
large data set of over maybe a couple
million rows and but then we were able
to I like key services by speaking with
local government expert which we brought
inside the network and has them which
area should journalists really focus on
and then produce smaller data set that
the journalists could focus on what was
interesting is that each one of them was
Denny
to find the key things for their own
areas and that's what they decided to
wrote on so the stories that the
journalist produced in this case were
very different from our national story
that we decided to focus on but there
was a wealth of everything
that's the last story we're working on
it's we're trying to get a centralized
account of Alma's death in the UK so
that relies on a few automations to find
whenever there's a local press really
local press article being written
there's obviously not a lot of
information on it it's often dismissed
as just a single case rather than
something systemic or just like oh the
poor guy died on the street because he
was cold or you did an overdose and not
trying to go and say well these are the
area where it happens the most and they
all have got kind of the same services
so this will be the end goal of this
investigations for now we have produced
just a display that kinds of pay homage
--is to the life and that tells their
story as much as we can a cool thing
about that is that the reporter can just
feel a Google spreadsheet and there's a
Python automation that then looks if the
spreadsheet is different than the one
committed to github and if so downloads
it and commits it to github so basically
a journalist that has no tech skill know
HTML know CSS no JavaScript no Python is
able to update the visual display of the
interactive on the website which I find
really nice and is the kind of skill
that can be brought to newsrooms as well
so that's the result of the work we've
done so far 13 months later there's
about 700 people so I've done the
network obviously not everyone is super
engaged a lot of people will decide
which investigation they want to take
part of but we have an increasing amount
of genuine interaction within the slack
about people just asking question and
before we can have an answer as a team
someone from someone else from the
network steps in and says yeah we'll do
that data visualization for you or I can
do that data work there was 169 just
local stories by local reporter produced
which are all it might not saying
like the biggest figure but it's good to
remember it's all investigations that
wouldn't have been possible because of
tech reasons to them and that our Hall
investigative by Nature and we've
produced about over 40 open resources
when its leader reporting recipes or
datasets or code that just shows a bit
about how to work with some of
government files that we work with and
we're really looking forward to do more
and if you're interested well this is
the bitly join bureau local and you'll
receive our next newsletter to know what
projects we work on next and if you're
interested I love to hear from anyone
here yeah most of the work we do is in
Python as well for the backend so it'll
be a pleasure thank you all
[Applause]